you kept asking me and you kept you know
check in how things are going should
have just been honest and transparent
from the GetGo bro if only you were
honest Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping the
reward click the link and donate what
you can
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well in this is a
video pertaining to the whole situation
that's happened with AK uh AK is
somebody I do not know personally um he
approached us 10 years ago I do not even
remember what it was I don't even know
what the video was about I'll try to if
I find a video I can play it for you
guys um I don't remember endorsing
anything specifically is we can work out
a a plan to make sure you get your full
money back okay or number two is you
could report me you could you could sue
me you could take me to jail but then
you're going to lose out on your money
then Ki so so that that Google sheet
that you showed us where I think it was
one of the months it it was it was like
May June July was one of those months
and
you my wife's going to know she's going
to divorce me I
think just want to come clean i' be
dishonest and I made mistakes that
should have opened up earlier I want to
apologize to you guys I just want to
come clean I know in the worst worst
case scenario I I'll admit that it's my
fault you none of you guys are to to
blame for anything you're just following
my lead and Direction but I just want to
come clean and I know that we can turn
this
around and now now that is building of
Legacy done for you know we can turn it
around but I just need you guys support
so we can get people's money back and
just turn this around
you kept asking me and you kept you know
trying
to you know check in how things are
going should have just been honest and
transparent from the
get-go
well all you did was by time yeah if you
were honest bro I've built multiple
businesses I could have [__] fixed it
all from the
beginning if only you were
honest uh but anyways yes so after that
um endorsement um he actually used our
video I would say about 6 months to a
year ago and Musa informed me about this
and he was very upset and I said you
know rightly so uh which is that he was
using our video to I don't know cuz as
we're a public influence he's probably
using that to draw more people in we're
going to come to all of that we're going
to discuss B sister's five main topics
I'm going to tell you guys how me and my
family actually this personal thing lost
over
£150,000 and I'm not talking about my
close course I'm talking about distance
relatives a lot of people and I'm going
to tell you the story of how that
happened and why it happened and the
lessons that I learned from that uh
Subhan Allah so we're going to come to
that insh brother and sisters so I'm
going to tell you the whole story but
before I come to I want to go to the
root of the problem why do these things
happen let me tell you why happened guys
the main one of the main reasons why
people are going down this route of
doing these Ponzi schemes yeah Ponzi
scheme is basically you have multiple
amounts of people you promis them a
specific um a a share or whatever it is
for that matter percentage every single
month um and you get people's money and
you channel that money basically it's
basically channel that money giving
people what you told them going to give
but you're basically using their money
and other people's money to make it seem
like they are making a profit on an
investment whatever it is but in reality
what they do is once they've governed
enough money 2 3 4 5 10 million 100
million whatever they disappear and go
that's how it works uh we was a part of
this uh we was um we got stung by this
kind of um fraud ourself so I'm going to
come to but before that brother and
sisters the first thing is the whole get
rich scheme yeah the get rich scheme
quick yeah the get quick Get Rich SCH
scheme that you see anywhere and
everywhere and now the Muslims have
jumped on board now look there is
nothing wrong with doing Tara there is
nothing wrong with doing business there
is nothing wrong with that but the idea
is that now it's turned into a like oh
you know you want to live this lifestyle
you want to do this you want to do that
they're in hotels supercars whatever I'm
doing Etc now look it's it's it's well
and good it's well and good to want that
for others but but this notion this
ideology this thought process of that
everyone you know like vilification of
the 9 to5 jobs as well is another issue
why are people made to feel that 9 to5
is something bad I've done 95 I've done
Uber I used to do Uber yes I used to
work as a Uber driver I done 95 when I
first came to Islam uh the same
situation the same situation I didn't I
was working in I can't remember Tesco I
don't know what it was yeah okay I don't
care because when I came to Islam I
freed myself from the shackles of what
people think about me where I work and
I'm and I measured my success and who I
am and the respect people give me is
based measured on what career I have or
how much money I own uh or what car I
drop I don't care bro I don't care I
left that Jia I come from a strict
background if you guys know Kurds and
Turks trust me all they talk about is
money money money money money money and
money I was sick to death of it so much
so I totally left I literally divorced
the whole materialism Lim I just had
enough man and I did not want anything
to do with it why because it makes me
sick whoever you go and talk to it's all
about money you're the people you talk
to you the respect you give to it's all
based on how much money he has it's all
all about that that's why in our
communities we have one of the highest
suicide rates why because those who
cannot reach that level do what I'm
worthless I have nothing to offer I'm a
nobody whatever it is uh and they take
their life you know there's many factors
to this so firstly I want to talk to
those people who are promoting this
liberal Western LIF you're a Muslim
you're a practicing person there is
nothing wrong with living a good life no
problem but why is living a good life
definition to you guys only money and
wealth why why is it that can it not be
that you use money for the sake of Allah
and for good things of course they plant
that in there and say yeah know it's for
this but you are promoting what
lifestyle that not many people can reach
not everyone if everyone became an
entrepreneur a millionaire the world
will not function you need people who do
95s now I'm not telling you to to 95 to
the rest of your life and even if you
did there is no damn problem what is the
problem I've done a video about this
long time ago about a Tik tocker who was
saying the same thing you know oh um I'm
not I don't want to be working in Tesco
my friend what is wrong with Tesco man
humble yourself what is wrong with
working in Tesco whatever it is for that
matter Halal income and income that is
halal it is what is beloved to Allah
Allah is not going to say did you do a
95 oh you're going Janam you're going
Hell Fire what are you guys on about so
these are the two factors that cause
people to go down the route of doing
fraud on the scheme and whatever is for
that factor and not only that as men we
are the maintainers and protectors and
providers so what that means is an extra
burden on our shoulders yes just as the
our sisters have the weakness of beauty
they love to Ador theirself they like to
show off whatever it is for that matter
for us men we have the burden of what
Pro protecting and providing which means
that when Brothers get to know sisters
for marriage and their criteria is I
want 50 Grand Mah what are you made out
of gold what are you what are you coming
to offer I'm so sorry what are you
offering offering the table okay please
excuse me sister but £50,000 for what
yeah
like some of them come with this mad mad
expectations and Subhan Allah like you
know you've done God knows what yes and
you're coming here now and asking for
50,000 Mah and I want this wedding that
wedding what that does is put pressure
on men to be like you know what I got
rejected by this suit or whatever is the
family were too concerned about how much
money I make it puts them into the cycle
of what I need to go and do Haram or
whatever it is to reach this threshold
so can be qualified do you see how FNA
in the land is arising because of this
it's these false expectation we give
when I met my wife I was an Uber driver
who was renting a Toyota Prius from the
company I didn't own it myself I would
be working I was in a debt not I wasn't
say debt I owed some money to people not
owed I'll come to the clarification
where all that led to yeah where you'll
hear my story of how I got scammed Etc
and where I was yeah when I met my wife
I said look this is my situation this
what I do whatever it is for that matter
we SP
my wife was happy the point is what you
having and Trust in Allah do not ever go
down the route of Haram do not go to the
point where you try to justify yourself
or try to put a specific lifestyle I
told my wife look listen what you see is
what you get okay I'm not you know a
multi whatever you think you know
apparently my net worth is a couple of
million pounds I don't know where that
money is if anyone knows where it is
please let me know okay so the point is
when I met my wife I made things clear
and alhamdulillah may Allah bless and
preserve my wife she accepted me she
didn't say oh you have a Toyota priest
oh you do Uber no she accepted me for
who I am and Allah subhana wa tal is the
one has control in these Affairs don't
think your money wealth is going to get
a good woman you have a lot of girls
none of them will be your wife brothers
so don't let that be a means that you
get caught up in this I need to get rich
and sisters you play a role in this in
in totality as families as well mothers
fathers this is a bigger issue the roots
of the problems are deeper so number one
the whole get rich things brothers who
was practicing whatever fear Allah fear
Allah stop vilifying and putting down
people who do n five yes that's number
one number two there is nothing wrong
with 9 to 5 we talk about that number
three trusting religious people my
friend let me give myself as an example
whatever you want to call me Ali needs
da Ali da whatever you want to call it
if I come to you and say I've got this
proposal and this a business and Etc
whatever you're not going to come and
say oh alwa he's a very righteous person
you don't know nothing about me by the
way yeah of course you have good but
you're going to say like you know you
can do your due diligence yes you have
to do your due diligence man you can't
just come and jump It's who cares man
who cares if it is you have to do the
biggest thing that we have with our
Muslims today this naivity and be I was
one of those I'll be honest with you
when I was looking to get married hij I
was thinking oh my gosh
she's the the the the wife she cannot
ever make mistakes I was believe me in
my marriage seeking process I came
across hijabis and and and oh boy oh boy
man the stuff that I found out or the
stuff that they would ask me in the
marriage getting to know the marriage
seing
process like so much so I was I said you
know what I came to a point in my life I
said I do not want to marry hijabi like
that's how bad it went and we don't want
that because now that's damaging the
scene because now people like okay who
can we trust and it shouldn't be like
that it shouldn't be like that so
religious people who are using religious
with their beard and whatever to lure
people in fear Allah man fear Allah this
is a responsibility and am man given to
you in the da we have the same we have
to be careful this an AM responsibility
we can't be Reckless we can't go and do
and may Allah protect us W what is your
weakness brother ask Allah I always ask
Allah protect me from this FNA this FNA
this FNA because it's not that when if
Ali gets caught slipping it's not going
to be Ali it's going to be Islam they're
not going to say Al da they're going say
oh this is Islam this is your religious
figure this is the da guy so may Allah
subhana protect us be careful do not
trust religious people trust me I've had
many examples like this where religious
looking people have done mad things
anyways let me come to the story of
myself and then we're going to talk
about the punishment of debt how severe
debt is in Islam three specific
narrations my story is the following
guys now I want you guys to listen
attentively okay when I first came to
Islam I was so sick to death of the
whole monetary money this that flying
there this W I was sick I left it I said
the only thing I want is this I can
remember clearly and I can remember this
is the time when I was kicked out my
house I was I was living in M's house
yeah they looked after me for three
months and so did Brother IM D and his
family they looked after him may Allah
bless and Preserve them and the the um
the point is this the point is this guys
yeah is that when I came I said you know
there's two things I want if I can
provide a Halal income for my family
whatever is needed I can pay my rent do
my shopping give some basic rights to my
wife whatever it is etc etc etc clothes
or whatever and I want to do da I don't
want anything else I don't want the cars
I don't want the houses I don't want the
ler I do not want nothing I just want to
do da just love that I feel in love with
Islam I I feel the true happiness the
contentment you know and I said that's
all I want to do bro Halal in come I
don't care if it's Tesco ug this I don't
care bro Halal in alhamdulillah is it
Halal good I can provide alhamdulillah
and after that I want to and again it's
goes to wives put pressures on their men
as well on their husbands AIC lify oh no
I want this I want that fear Allah the
man has that responsibility stop pushing
that pressure making him feel inadequate
that he is's going to go and do you know
invest your money in Ponzi schemes like
this so he can give you a better
lifestyle and you lose everything be
content like we know the story of Abra
Alam with his son you know you know the
story about him saying you know coming
to his U wife's son house and saying how
is your Affairs how's my son and she
complains oh you know uh you know we're
not eating enough or whatever Etc he
said when my son comes tell him to
change his door gate gate whatever the
Gate of the house or something like that
and when his son comes he says your
father came and said this this he said
my father said for me to divorce you and
then he divorc him he gets married again
and his father ibraim Alam comes back
and says the same thing to his new wife
how is he alhamdulillah we're good
whatever little we have we're doing good
alhamdulillah all praise to Allah he
said when my son comes tell him to keep
his gate and he said she said this thing
to uh his son and his son said my father
said to keep you it is very important
for us to have grateful and I'm sorry
I'll be very honest because I don't care
about call me misogynist or whatever you
want to call me but I don't give a damn
women in their nature are ungrateful and
don't blame me please don't the prophet
said the majority of the inhabitants of
the Hell Fire who woman why they are
they ungrateful to Allah to Allah no no
no to who to their husbands their
husbands will do so much good when they
do one thing bad they'll say I've never
seen any good from you so this is a
weakness in our sisters and the prophet
said give give them a solution yes so
when I came to Islam this is what I was
want to do couple years later cuz I
didn't monetize my YouTube channel
because of the har I did not monetize it
for a good four or five years an
opportunity came through a uncle yes and
this opportunity was that basically
there's investment in crude oil I said
okay I mean that's fine he told me about
it Etc I saw the contracts whatever I
mean I didn't go too much into detail
but it was an opportunity I said well
okay why not I had some money saved and
I invested my own money in that and I
was getting a and I was getting a
monthly revenue from that and I thought
it was working for me it was just like
that extra couple of hundred pound
whatever month it was working for me so
I went to I said can I like if I bring
other investors like can it work and he
just he said look you can be the
middleman for that that matter and you
know I was making um I was from that
afterwards I introduced other people yes
even some people in the da scene were
involved yeah why because I feel look
I'm a kind of person if Allah's blessed
me with something I want to see people I
love around me to increase with me do
you get what I'm trying to say I don't
want to be like you know like I wanted
them to increase with me so anyways this
happened I got other people invol I said
look I've put my own money I'm just
letting you guys I've put my own money
he's working for me it's it's investment
in Commodities that's what I said and
they said you I said yes you know I
don't see anything wrong the the uncle
is a religious person etc for that
matter whatever it is you know so I said
look again and we invested and other
people invested and believe me I was
making ridiculous amounts of money
ridiculous amounts of money so much so I
told you guys I'm not Money Motivated I
don't care W I would give a lot of that
money to my father to invest somewhere I
would say just Dad I just need this much
a month just to whatever it keep me
going and 80% of that wealth I would
just say dad I don't know what to do
with it cuz I just want to do da I'm not
concerned about making I don't care so I
just gave it to my father to
invest time went Etc different
opportunities were coming through this
Uncle Etc some of them were things that
I was I did not I was like I don't know
what it is I don't understand that this
all like financial terms Etc I said I
don't know what that is I just want to
stick to this basic thing with my
investors with the investors so couple
years down the line all things went peir
shaped the uncle himself from what I
know cuz I to assume the best was a
victim of the Ponzi scheme himself yes
of course there was some mistakes I made
in a way I'm not going to get into the
details of that but he himself was also
um you know lost his wealth and lot and
very bad place everything collapsed the
money I made uh from that uh basically I
lost 80% of it why because my family
members got involved my grandmother's
own money my mother's money my father
got other family members involved he
vouched for them that if you know cuz my
dad's not Muslim he said to them if your
money is lost I will I don't know why he
said that till this day my dad's paying
that debt till this day my grandmother
and another elderly uh aunti who
invested money I don't owe them anything
cuz it was a investment we thought it
was an investment I took the burden of
those funds that they lost on myself and
said out of Goodwill because you guys
are elderly I'm going to pay that out of
my pocket until this day I am slowly
slowly paying that even though it was
not a large large amount but the point
was what I was with that debt and and
believe me it was one of the biggest
Trials of my life not just the well
forget that I lost everything and I'm
not going to get into details of my
story one day I'll share with you guys I
lost
everything everything let me say put it
like that yeah and alhamd it was the
best thing that ever happened to me well
was the best thing ever happened
alhamdulillah so from that day on I
learned a lesson I am never ever going
to ever get anybody involved if I do it
if I do and and that I'm not going to do
as well I'm never going to trust anybody
and there all this kind of stuff W there
were people who got so greedy they went
behind my back cuz if they came to me
there was this new scheme that the the
uncle was saying Etc whatever it is I
didn't know what it was I said look I
don't know I told the ones who investing
through me like I don't know what that
is let's just stick to the commodity
invest whatever A lot of people got
greedy they went behind my back and they
lost hundreds of thousands if not
millions and I found out this later when
they told me I was like bro you didn't
invest that money for me I don't
remember that you get it and obviously
they knew what was happening they
they went behind my back got a bit
greedy and invested hundreds of
thousands I've heard if not millions of
euros and all of that
money go and I was like alhamd Allah you
protected me because imagine they would
have blamed me for it yeah but sadly
many people also lost thousands of
pounds I think in the estimation of
anywhere from2 to4 million was
gone and Subhan Allah Subhan Allah so to
me sorry
so to me that was a massive life lesson
you know again I was not somebody who
was seeking the like you know the lav
Allah is my witness I am someone if the
opportunity is there I don't go out my
way I just knew the uncle he said
there's I said no problem Uncle I've got
this much money can I invest yep I saw
Revenue coming and I just wanted the
same thing for my loved ones my friends
around me Etc and it was just that but I
saw Subhan Allah that when it comes to
this stuff we can't just blind like oh
okay the uncle is religious or this and
and again we need to do research to see
maybe this Aon scheme that we can even
help the uncle to make him realize but
when you're just like no you just put
your trust Etc this is our problem the
problem is that we easily trust as
Muslims we are very naive and we trust
easily and I think that is connected to
what because you want to get rich so
fast so quick that you just I mean come
on people are investing in place I'm
like why would you invest with that
person bro but it happens it happens a
lot of people lost money it destroys so
many people's lives my concern was
forget all of that I was like
the debt is such a great sin and I'm
going to end with this three narrations
I was
thinking to this Uncle like all these
people's money was involved as well
we're not fully blaming him but all
these people's money got lost yeah and
then what happens is when you go into
this spiral when you realize it's upon
this game like AK did he realized oh
crap I need to get this money back to
the people so what did he do he lies
further and by the way this a video
that's come out he's again accusation I
don't want to get into no any legal
battle please allow me yeah I ain't got
time for that to try to do da yeah so
he's come out and he basically what
happens and this goes back to the
narration of the Prophet listen this for
yourself it goes back to exactly that
what did the prophet say look look at
this yeah this is what happens okay it
was narrated a may Allah be peace with
him okay he said oh Allah I seek Refuge
from you from sin and debt someone said
to him how often do you see Refuge from
debt he said he said when a man gets in
debt he speaks and tells lies and he
makes promises and breaks it okay so the
point is what when you're in that spiral
what happens is you end up lying you
have to end up lying and then you're
taking more people's money to pay other
people off with the ideal because you're
stuck now you hundreds of thousands of
millions of pounds you thinking how I'm
going to get that you still luring
people fear Allah look at this look let
me look it was narrated by we were
sitting with the m of Allah peace be
peace and blessings Allah be upon him
when he raised his heads towards the sky
and and then put his palm on the
forehead and said Subhan Allah what a
strict issue has been revealed to me we
remain silent and were afraid the
following morning we asked him oh M of
Allah what is the strict issue that has
been revealed he said he said by the one
who who has whose hand is my soul if man
were killed in a battle for the sake of
Allah then brought back to life and then
killed in the um and brought back life
again and killed and he ow the debt he
would not enter Paradise until his debt
was paid off and he refrained from
offering the funeral prayer of the one
who had died owing just two Dinars until
abuat May Allah be pleas be pleased with
him has promised to pay it offer him
when he saw him the following day he
said I have paid it off the prophet
Muhammad him said now the skin has
become cool for him in a nut show guys
my point is what this is how severe debt
is this is how severe debt is and let me
tell you something W it's it's we my di
with this whole situation ET till this
day we we had to make so much changes
Etc whatever to I don't want to get into
details but that debt is still this day
being paid and I still have something
not it's not a debt on me but I've have
good willll said look you guys lost your
money I'm going to pay because it was it
was it was it was an investment so I
never took thatb from anybody may Allah
protect us from debt but my point is
what guys please for the sake of Allah
be content and happy like Allah says if
you're grateful I will increase you not
increase you in wealth increase you in
contentment maybe Allah doesn't specify
what it is stop chasing the D the cause
the Lish life this how do you know this
brings happiness man ask Allah for
Baraka ask Allah for Baraka man please
guys and this is where I believe the
whole situation stems from don't trust
anybody easily even myself I'm very very
careful who are indoors who are work I'm
very very careful so please guys protect
yourself and like I said before
alhamdulillah it was a lesson for me it
taught many things alhamdulillah but W
guys losing money wealth debt my concern
is let me tell you something
how are you bro bro I don't know I don't
know the mess you got into may Allah
give you a way out and pay these
people's money bro how are you going to
stand in front of Allah I don't want you
to lose hope I know you're going to be
watching this video bro yeah what you
did was har on a different level bro
yeah you're already down I'm not going
to kick you may Allah give you way out
to pay the people's debt bro W I don't
know how you're going to stand in front
of Allah bro bro may Allah like I said I
don't want to make you despair well I
don't I'm genuinely saying may Allah
make your Affairs easy and that you give
the HCK of the people that you took bro
you all you have to do is work whatever
you have to do bro pay those people off
man before you die may Allah protect us
guys anything I said wrong is from
myself and Shan anything good is from
Allah and his messenger till next
time the prophet sallu alhi wasallam
said whoever builds a Masjid for the
sake of Allah subhana tala Allah will
build for him a similar house in jenah
on that day where Allah subhana tal
tells us that our books will be given
and every little atam we of Good Deed
you've done will be there and imagine
you see a mountain and you're like what
a lucky person which righteous person
and Allah says this is for you for me
yes what did I do you allowed people to
pray you built a Masid I never had the
money to build a Masid Allah you helped
you gave towards it and Allah gives you
the reward of as if you built it donate
now guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra Rewards
l